you like my baby photo me too you know
what Roger I have another day a crime
what a while
mmm-hmm because everybody wants to be
the king
hey youtubers is Charlie so we got new
Luke Cage let's break it down just
talking more about the importance of
hip-hop in the Marvel Universe if you
weren't a fan of hip-hop before Luke
Cage after you watch all the episodes
you definitely will be this is actually
from more of the footage that they
showed off at comic-con you like my
Biggie poster everybody wants to be the
king so the poster itself just looks
really badass but it's actually really
important to his character he is like a
self-styled kingpin based on the way the
characters described in this series I
wouldn't say he has his [ __ ] together
quite as much as kingpin kingpins
definitely the most powerful crime boss
in the city but cottonmouth is kind of
like the kingpin of Harlem he has all
these legitimate businesses he's related
to Mariah Dillard who's played by alfre
woodard
she's like a community leader who seems
like a really nice person but she has
deep ties to crime in the community so
she's actually one of the big bads of
the series - I think she's gonna be a
really amazing terrifying villain in the
vein of jeryn hogarth if you watch
Jessica Jones or if you didn't watch
Jessica Jones she's more of a good
character that does very terrible things
like if someone makes a joke about
lawyers being terrible people jeryn
hogarth is that stereotype just a really
terrible morally ambiguous attorney so
Mariah Dillard's character is kind of
that same type of care to someone with
great power that uses it for their own
personal gain that hides behind this
public persona like we're trying to make
this community better but secretly they
have all this crime stuff going on on
the side like kingpin so while kingpin
is still gonna be by favorite Marvel
villains so far next to David Tennant's
purple man you'll have a lot of fun
seeing how some of these other
characters are very similar but also
very different very different types of
villains with very different motivations
but cottonmouth as you know has history
with Luke Cage
so that'll go back into his origin story
we'll see that play out through the
series but the really cool thing that
you don't necessarily get from this
trailer is that this Biggie poster is
hanging inside of cottonmouths nightclub
he owns a bunch of businesses but all of
the episodes featured this nightclub
that's kind of a central location that
forms part of the backbone of the
structure of each of the episodes so
music is really important to this series
it's kind of like Marvel's the get-down
if you haven't watched the get-down it's
this Netflix series by Baz Luhrmann
about the birth of hip-hop in New York
City so I talked about how each of the
episode titles is based on a gang star
song well within the show they feature
very specific music that's important for
each episode but it happens at
cottonmouths nightclub like they have
singers come into the nightclub in
perform so hip-hop music is really
important to telling the story of Luke
Cage the way they tell the story in what
it says about all the characters
themselves so just pay attention to the
way they structure episodes around the
performances at cottonmouths nightclub
during episodes when these drop now
remember the episodes don't drop til
September 30th on Friday but you can
actually get them all midnight on the
29th so like if you don't have school or
you don't care about going to work the
next day like you're gonna call in sick
you can actually start watching all the
episodes at midnight but my first video
like my episode 1 video won't post till
later in the day on Friday so you don't
have to worry about that but what you
guys think about that I'll say
congratulations to this week's Captain
America giveaway winner Justin Martinez
you and an Amazon gift card is basically
for the value of the Civil War blu-ray
so just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details so what's gonna
happen next is I'll be doing a Wolverine
mr. sinister video they just announced
that mr. sinister who's part of like the
post-credits scene and x-men apocalypse
is going to officially appear in
Wolverine 3 and remember that movies
dropping in March so we're gonna get a
trailer for that really soon and they
just confirmed the first villain for
Punisher Season 1 they're still casting
the series they haven't started shooting
it yet they won't actually start
shooting punisher episodes to like early
next year so they'll be casting people
for the rest of the year so video for
that should post at least by tomorrow so
Wolverine coming later tonight then
punisher then there's a bunch more
Marvel DC stuff coming and they didn't
drop it in time for my video the other
day but they released the official look
of Ghost Rider when he's in Ghost Rider
form on agents of shield so this is what
he's gonna look like when he's walking
around burning people's souls which is
pretty badass I think it's pretty good
considering the budget the TV has to
work with so Newville dream coming later
tonight get hype what do you guys wait
for that to pose
you can click here for the new Ghost
Rider trailer and you can click here for
Ironman for height thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you